Viviane... j'étais en train de tapoter ma
tasse de café comme t'as fais dans
ta dernière vidéo,  j'ai trempé ma tartine dans ma tasse de café
et là,  ça a fait des gouttes super bizarres !
Waohhhhh !
Comment çà des trucs bizarres... des
gouttes ?
Figure toi que j'ai trouvé des chercheurs qui ont étudié ça !
Il  y a des chercheurs qui travaillent sur la science de la tartine beurrée alors ?
Des chercheurs de Grenoble se sont
intéressés à la forme et à l'évolution
de certaines gouttes que l'on peut voir
se former à la surface d'un liquide
comme le thé ou le café lorsqu'il est mis en contact avec un liquide gras comme le beurre fondu.
On voit des gouttes de gras qui s'étendent très rapidement
et si on regarde bien,  on voit se former ce qui ressemble à des trous
à l'intérieur de ces gouttes, et ses trous semblent  être éjectés.
Rassurez-vous,  les chercheurs ont bien
conscience qu'il s'agit d'analyser une
pratique très française et considérée
comme révoltante par certains spécialistes du thé.
Tremper sa tartine beurrée dans sa boisson !
Mais ce type de phénomène peut aussi se retrouver dans l'industrie,  lorsque deux liquides non
miscibles sont mis en contact.
Revenons à ma tartine dans le café.
Les chercheurs de Grenoble ont décidé de
partir justement de cette constatation
pour appliquer toutes les étapes de la
méthode scientifique : simplifier le problème
Formuler une hypothèse ;  Elaborer
un protocole expérimental reproductible ;
Confirmer (ou pas) l'hypothèse et relier
ce phénomène aux études existantes.
Ils ont tout d'abord essayé de trier les
paramètres importants de ceux qui
n'avaient probablement que peu
d'influence sur le phénomène.
Est-ce que le café est important pour l'apparition
des gouttes ?
Non, ça marche aussi avec du thé,  de l'eau
chaude et même de la glycérine.
Et sa température ?
Non, tant que le beurre est fondu en surface.
Est-ce que la qualité de la matière
grasse est importante ?
Oui, ça marche seulement avec du beurre
et de l'huile naturelle etc etc.
Ils ont ainsi réduit leur étude à un
problème beaucoup plus simple :
Une huile végétale ou animale en contact avec de l'eau.
Et cela donne bien le phénomène qui nous intéresse.
Ensuite,  ils ont formulé une hypothèse : Première étape,  le beurre
de la tartine fond et crée des grandes gouttes
or ces gouttes contiendraient certaines
impuretés aqueuses qui vont jouer le rôle
de tensioactifs,  ces molécules souvent
connues pour faciliter la formation entre
deux liquides non miscibles : Vous savez,
c'est notre fameux liquide vaisselle...
Waow !
Secret de printemps !
Par endroits,  la couche de gras devient très fine
or les impuretés qui sont présentes dans
la goutte se déposent peu à peu et
libèrent au contact du fond de la goutte
des molécules de tensioactifs.
À cet endroit,  le gras perd son affinité avec
l'eau et un trou se forme,  et pour
expliquer le déplacement des trous,  les
chercheurs remarquent que les gouttes de
gras ont une forme de lentille à la
surface de l'eau. Elles sont plutôt
bombées au centre et plus fines en bordure.
Ils en déduisent que les trous
se déplaceraient vers les bords des
gouttes,  là où l'épaisseur de gras est plus faible.
Voilà pour les hypothèses.  Comment les prouver maintenant ?
Et bien en réalisant une expérience reproductible avec des ingrédients
strictement nécessaires et
des paramètres contrôlés.
Les scientifiques ont choisi de l'huile
végétale qu'ils ont filtré pour enlever
toutes les impuretés,
puis ils y ont ajouté une quantité connue
d'une molécule de tensioactifs produite
en laboratoire : une solution de lauryl-
sulfate de sodium, et en déposant ce
mélange délicatement sur l'eau...
Cette expérience crée le même phénomène
que le beurre de ma tartine dans ma
tasse de café, donc les chercheurs ont bien identifié
les bons paramètres et ils valident
ainsi leur hypothèse.
Ils montrent que cette expérience simple modélisant
la tartine dans le café reproduit une variété de
phénomènes jusque là étudiés séparément :
Il y a une forme de propulsion des gouttes de gras lors de l'éjection des trous.
Il y a des gouttes qui dansent.
Et lorsqu'il y a assez de gras,  un film de
gras percé d'une multitude de trous
peut se former,  couvrant la totalité de
la surface du liquide.
Et vous pourrez vous aussi facilement observer cette
figure en dentelle si vous plongez
directement une noisette de beurre dans
votre café.
Le gras,  c'est la vie !
Les chercheurs montrent donc que ces gouttes
traversées par des trous sont une nouvelle
manifestation de ce que les physiciens
appellent les effets Marangoni,  du nom du
physicien italien Carlo Marangoni.
Des phénomènes qui apparaissent à l'interface entre
deux liquides non
miscibles en présence de tensioactif.
Et on en avait d'ailleurs fait une vidéo
qui s'appelle les gouttes qui pulsent.
L'étude de ces phénomènes est très
précieuse pour les professionnels de la
peinture,  de l'impression,  du revêtement
technique,  mais aussi de la cuisine, car
elle permet d'améliorer les processus de
fabrication.
Donc,  en trempant leur tartine dans le
café,  il y a quand même des chercheurs qui
ont mis en évidence un nouvel effet Marangoni, c'est quand même fou !
C'est fou cet effet Marangoni parce
qu'on le trouve vraiment à plein
d'endroits différents,
et d'ailleurs je t'invite à venir voir
sur ma chaîne,  j'ai une petite
manifestation encore de ce même effet
mais qui est très esthétique.
Voilà pour cet épisode un peu spécial
qui montre que la méthode scientifique peut s'appliquer pour analyser les phénomènes du quotidien.
Et qu'il n'y a pas besoin d'en faire des tartines pour faire des découvertes passionnantes.
N'hésitez pas à aller faire un tour sur
la chaîne Scilabus pour voir l'épisode
de Viviane et profitez-en pour regarder
les gouttes qui pulsent,  un autre épisode de Zeste de Science.
Est-ce que le café est important pour
l'apparition des....